d'accord, je voulais vous montrer
ça depuis un moment, donc nous avons euh quatre
couvertures différentes pour l'album de minuit
et
si vous les retournez, il y a évidemment
une couverture arrière pour chacune d'elles, elles sont
chacune différentes mais qu'est-ce que je  Je voulais
te montrer que si tu mets toutes les
couvertures arrière ensemble,
c'est une horloge
c'est une horloge,
ça pourrait t'aider à lire l'heure
oh mon dieu
ça a l'air si incroyable
allez stephen
allez
stephen
c'est bon c'est bon ok
c'est assez  pour aujourd'hui
c'est assez
stephen c'est assez pour aujourd'hui
maman hmm
est-ce que tu m'aimes autant que je t'aime d'accord
descends attends attends est-ce que tu m'aimes
autant que j'en ai l'air oui
mais vraiment
oui mais vraiment
[Musique]
oh
tu es si beau
[Applaudissements]
allons-y allons-y
[Musique]
pas de
gourou majoritaire